[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages uh so time to see what's
making the headlines with the
broadcaster and former government
minister anna subray and the pr
consultant alex dean welcome and lovely
to see both of you
as ever it is time for the front pages
so let's start with the guardian leading
on multiple nhs trusts across england
declaring critical incidents staff
absences saw due to covid
the eye focuses on nhs leaders warning
boris johnson over growing covet
staffing shortages
the delhi telegraph quotes a leading
vaccine expert who says we can't jab the
whole planet every six months
the daily express leading with the prime
minister vowing that sticking to his
plan will be the way out of the pandemic
as he has quoted saying the omicron
strain is considerably milder than
previous variants
that's also the lead for the times we're
on the right path says the pm
but says the mail many of us can expect
a return to covert chaos from today as
more than a million people are forced to
isolate
it is eating or heating as millions of
families face energy bill rises this
year that's the lead story for the metro
financial times reports how apple has
become the first company to hit a market
capitalization of three trillion dollars
and the daily star says the rush to
inhabit mars has been put off after a
scientist warned astronauts would turn
cannibal if things went wrong
they've had a run of stories like this
haven't they anyway they're having some
fun as everybody heads back to work
which is kind of what tuesday's all
about and uh these are tuesday's papers
are they not um and the the daily
telegraph alex tackling this idea of
vaccination as the root out of it and
where you draw the line so what is um
what's this leading expert telling us
telegraph was occurred in an interview
with sir andrew pollard who is the
chairman of the joint committee on
immunization and vaccination and it is a
vaccination an immigration and it is a
fascinating read on the front not only
does he say that we can't be jabbing
everybody every six months which isn't
just a statement it's an answer to a
question that many of us will have had
are we going to be doing this every six
months to which this leading expert's
answer is no he also goes on to say in
remarks that i think will be widely
reported here and elsewhere that when
emanuel macron and angela merkel spread
his word misinformation about the
astrazeneca vaccine which of course we
were widely using in the uk and was
later used in continental europe he says
that that misinformation will have led
to deaths in africa because of people
being more cautious than they should
have been about taking vaccines as a
result of that indeed he says that um
comments made in mainland europe have
real ramifications in africa to which
one might add i suppose they have
consequences in france and germany as
well yeah professor andrew pollard
correct me if i'm wrong connected to the
oxford jab so you know that that's his
uh that's the the baby as it were um but
but certainly people in this country
who've had a third primary job namely
the amino compromised will get a fourth
jab their booster and also uh israel we
know um only this week uh said that they
would be fourth jabbing healthcare
workers and those over 60. so the
precedent is being set by the nation we
kind of follow which is which is israel
the the problem is anna i guess is if
the booster
lasts at full capacity for only 10 weeks
the vulnerable older cohorts are coming
to the end of their booster run
um with with full antibody just when we
get these enormous omicron cases so
there's a sort of a danger there isn't
there
look there's a there's a danger that if
we all run away with things before we
know all the facts and all the evidence
we could get things badly wrong so we
know that the history of these sorts of
viruses is that they
they burn themselves out because
effectively they run out of hosts and
they mutate i mean apparently spanish
flu is still around for example 100
years ago it first struck but in very
small numbers and as we know that that
these sorts of um
diseases they as we say mutate but we
don't quite know and yes the evidence is
looking good on omnicron but you know we
know there are other consequences
as the number of infections is rising
and we know that the effect it's having
on the nhs so i just think that before
we all rush to what would be
fantastically happy conclusions that
somehow it's all over
let's just be cautious and actually the
thing that i took away from andrew
pollard of course the telegraph has a
bit of a gender here
but i took away from his um interview
with them was this fact about the
unvaccinated and the terrible
misinformation that's being spread
um especially on
social media facebook and on twitter
especially facebook she's just blatant
lies we know that the overwhelming
majority of people in hospital on the
copied wards with kobe omnicron or delta
are people who have not been vaccinated
and i personally think we should be
taking tough measures to stop this
misinformation of dangerous material on
social media it's a bit tricky isn't it
when some of that misinformation is
coming from heads of government and
heads of state as he points out but i we
should be clear no no that's that's a
lot of what i'm saying there's a big
difference
in saying that nobody is going to be um
receiving a job so he does go on to say
that some people in the country will
need to have further jabs i mean no
suppressed people being part of it
people who are vulnerable may need
further protections what he's talking
about when saying we're not going to
have to vaccinate every 16 months is
whole population efforts and that really
is very good news
and the idea well
the phrase the phrase used by the prime
minister today is that it is omicron is
considerably milder the first time he's
gone so far so the idea that it's a
common cold the problem is we now seem
to be in a situation where we had 50 000
cases a day with delta we now have 150
000 cases a day uh with omicron which is
suddenly becoming normalized that that's
okay despite the fact that people having
to to isolate so we come onto the eye um
about staffing crises
every industry will have a staffing
crisis uh at 150 000 plus cases a day so
you know at what point do we start to
realize that you either treat it as a
common cold or you or you don't and this
is the difficult
phase we're in now anna
yeah but let's be careful really careful
for some people it definitely has been
nothing more than
just a heavy cold that's not the case
with everybody and that includes people
who are double vaccinated i have people
in my own family who've had it and were
really quite poorly but they weren't in
hospital and at the end of the day
that's what it's all about it's about
people being in hospital but you're
absolutely right the eye is right in
other newspapers as well is that because
it is there are so many cases now with
the rules saying that you've got to
isolate for at least 10 days seven days
if you have the two negative tests
that's having a huge knock-on effect not
just in the nhs which is already under
the most extraordinary stress
um and
it is really concerning what's happening
in the nhs but it also will have
knock-on offense in the in the public
sector in in my new game if you like
back at the criminal bar it's going to
have an effect on the criminal justice
system and getting jurors to sit and so
forth so that this is going to be a very
difficult couple of months i reckon
especially as it's winter and we know
that the nhs in particular suffers in
the winter um through the trips and
slips that come because of other
illnesses that people get because of the
time of year so this is a very tricky
two months we should not be under any
illusions about that so if it is still
dangerous for many people including the
unvaccinated which is obviously what
bruce johnson was again talking about
today and even for you know those of us
with older parents and children at
school who are very likely then to get
it and you might get it and then you
feel like you can't see your old
relatives this whole knock-on effect
really um at what point do
you know does it does it does it give or
should mitigations come in and are the
reasons they are not is because
politically boris johnson simply can't
do it the daily mail covered chaos fear
as million isolate as we all head back
to work so is it simply because of the
politics that he can't do it alex is
that why i don't think well that's a
really good question and i think we're
like very likely to follow the lead um
the americans have set and cut the
isolation period to five days and i
think that if um
to be fair johnson totally ruled that
out today and said that you know for
reasons of infectivity
it could be worse for stuff
yeah i know i think it's very likely
we're going to have to not least because
that's part of what unions and medical
practitioners are urging us to do to get
people back to the front line now
there's quite a lot in what anna said
that i've got to agree with actually
it's true that one of the most important
things is what the hospitalization rate
is and whilst the infection rate is a
great deal higher now than it was this
time last year the hospitalization rate
isn't which implies that our vaccination
program is a success so again i agree
with anna people should go out and get
their job but then part after that which
i think is worth remembering too
is that some people will be able to work
from home while self-isolating if their
condition is no worse than a cold but
many many people will not and ultimately
if we're going to be able to restore our
economy something that matters so much
and isolations and restrictions and
heaven forbid lockdowns are terrible for
people's mental health for the lonely
for the vulnerable in the end we're
going to have to get to a point where we
can live with it and the debate is about
when that point is but there is a
difference between a lockdown and
mitigation isn't there sorry sorry anna
i interrupted you
no no forgive me i think i think i think
nothing wrong with agreeing alex it's
rather good when people different
political views come together and agree
especially something as important as
this but i think there's something we do
have to remember that nhs workers are
often obviously on the front line with
people who have are ill
may have all sorts of vulnerabilities
through their illness and so they
we have to be absolutely certain that
they are not infected when they return
to work and it it may be that
for some reason or somehow it might be
different for people who aren't
obviously doing those sorts of jobs but
don't let's just get into this really
dangerous territory of saying oh well we
would just cut the rates down and the
other important thing is you're
absolutely right
that boris johnson suffers from two
things one
he's lost the trust of the british
people so people when he says whatever i
think he says people go well actually
i'm not sure i can believe anything this
man says anymore but he's absolutely
right i think he's more concerned about
the political fallout because he's in
big trouble i don't think he's going to
be prime minister this time next year um
but he's in political trouble and so
that is the thing that is guiding him
how he can win votes and keep what
little confidence he still has in his
own back benches that counts more than
actually doing the right thing by public
health uh and the dale express uh once
again quoting we're on the right path
the mention of plan b six times in a six
minute interview um but chris hopson uh
ceo of nhs providers today pointing out
the hospitalization figures over the
last seven days a national increase of
75 percent
uh the northeastern yorkshire with the
highest at 119
but he did point out that the rate of
growth in london case is still going up
that means is definitely is definitely
falling so that's what you have to
hold on to uh but it does appear that
the rest of the uk outside london is
about 10 days behind so there's there's
still you know there's still data to
wash through the system is there not
alex
yeah i think that's right and but you
were talking about a
parts of the country being 10 days
behind london not
10 weeks or even months and i think
that's a very positive thing to point to
the point is that vaccinations work we
should have faith in what we've executed
yes people should get vaccinated if you
haven't been jabbed yes we should have a
booster but we should be looking to
unlock society now after all in the end
the most important things are whether
people have to go to hospital with this
condition or whether very sadly they die
and it looks like broadly speaking this
is a great deal milder as everyone has
been saying and that it's we have broken
the link between infection and
hospitalization because of our great
vaccination program that's a really
positive thing i understand why people
want to caveat all their remarks but we
should be willing in the end to say
there is light at the end of the tunnel
and we are going to be able to get back
to normal and just one final thought
about the politics as we as we return
this week or people return to work we're
obviously already here
um it is wednesday isn't it anna uh it
looks like a cabinet meeting in the
morning there was a very frank
discussion in cabinet we understand
before christmas looks like sadie javid
will be speaking to the commons uh on
wednesday afternoon presumably whether
people want to hear more about face
masks in schools which certainly has not
made a number of conservatives happy if
you were around that cabinet table what
would you be wanting that was different
from what is being done
well i mean i i
call me old-fashioned but i would
actually be wanting to know what the
scientific advice is
and where where they say we and we now
are
and whether we need to do more i think
there's a i think there's a really very
strong argument that the government has
not done a very good job when it comes
to jabbing um youngsters over the age of
12
and that what's happening in the schools
that there are certain things that
should definitely have been done the
government's been slow whether it's been
putting in ventilation as i say whether
it's been doing a proper job on the on
on vaccinations and i think that the
other piece of work that really has done
so i think i said this the last time it
was on your program if not even earlier
is that we still haven't got into the
unvaccinated in the way that we need to
and we now really need to get into that
five million and get as many of them
jabbed up so there's still a lot of work
to be done to make sure that we're doing
the right thing and quick 30 seconds
same question for you alex although less
chance to be on the cabinet than than
obviously anna
whatever you say let's see
i i would say anna that most significant
part of the politics here is what the
executive decides to do
uh in advice form which isn't voted on
in the house of commons and doesn't have
a backstop time limit on it so we had
lots of debates in the commons before
the recent relatively mild restrictions
were announced but the working from home
advice is just that it's advice from
government given by government contrary
to ana's position people still do listen
to government hence all of us working
from home now that's not something that
anyone had a chance to vote about and
that in the end is a political issue
okay the the debate will rage no doubt
uh when parliament goes back this week
thank you for the moment lots more still
to come
we will look at the guardian next they
write that epstein paid duke's accuser
five hundred thousand dollars to commit
to that case in just a minute
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview uh with me now the
broadcaster and former government
minister anna subri and the pr
consultant alex dean welcome back to
both of you um picture on a number of
the newspapers as you might expect is
prince andrew the court case being heard
on tuesday after the release of
documents which showed that his accuser
virginia g frey was paid five hundred
thousand dollars alex
that's right kick off ten o'clock um
tomorrow uh u.s time in the morning and
it looks like a sizable payment was made
to uh this accuser by jeffrey epstein in
which she apparently undertook not just
to bring actions against him but not to
bring actions against people associated
with him which would include prince
andrew prince andrews legal team have
been briefing quite widely that they
think this is going to prevent the case
going ahead against prince andrew that
to me sounds rather a stretch on the
other hand as both anna and i would
probably want to stress there are
different standards that exist between
criminal and civil suits the suit that
was prevailed that prevailed against
elaine maxwell was a civil suit that
prince andrew faces criminal charges
okay full coverage of that obviously
around other way around no sorry it's
the other way around other way right
alex all right no you don't worry you
said civil for islam in fact that was a
criminal set of proceedings this is a
civil set of proceedings from the
guthrie against prince andrew thank
goodness i'm led by council absolutely
and uh last minute on um if if omicron
will take us in crisis mode from through
january and feb um
in at the start of april we'll we'll
start to see an energy crisis really hit
won't we if you look at the metro yeah
this is going to be the big
difficulty for boris johnson is the
squeeze now in the economy and some
really tough times for a lot of people
and it says in the metro eating or
heating it says in the metro that energy
bills are going to go up by april by 46
and then in august another rise of 20
and that is really going in a difficult
time of course taxes have gone up for a
lot of working families this is going to
put the squeeze on them and johnson is
getting a lot of grief again from his
benches extraordinary you know intervene
these are conservatives intervene in the
market take 20 off fuel bills
extraordinary political times but a real
difficulty for johnson i don't think
you'll be able to ride this one out um
but it will it will be difficult for
families interesting okay alex i know
you'll want to come in but it's schools
back tomorrow we need to know if there
it's rain max or not
so for the moment anna subre and alex
dean thank you both very much indeed
thank you and uh we'll see at half 11 as
well for more to the weather then